Now that we have our approach in mind,
as we start to work on the problem,
we need to prepare our data.
This generally involves gathering,
cleansing, formatting, blending, and
sampling the data.
In this lesson, we're going to start
with a data set that doesn't need any
work and is ready for analysis.
We'll spend an entire course
learning about data preparation,
so we'll skip it here.
Now that we have our data ready,
the next step in the problem solving
framework is to perform the analysis and
develop a model.
We mentioned that we're going to
use a Linear Regression model for
this problem.
But first,
let's learn a little about Linear
Regression before we create the model.